what you want to hear rapper hand up
down here yeah
the civil war wonderful just
straight out of the gate at the british
boy who i don't if you know this in
england we don't learn about that as
soon as
as soon as we lost this country we were
like well it's yours now
we don't care the civil war the civil
war we'll take that as a suggestion uh
hand up on the front row yes
azerbaijan and you pronounced it in a
way that suggests are you from
azerbaijan
no it's just because you said azerbaijan
and i was like i always thought it was
azerbaijan
and now i've been educated you're a
travel blogger oh
get you well done what's what's your
favorite thing about azerbaijan
it's great architecture i'm glad you
said that because i was looking for some
helpful info
the civil war azerbaijan and its great
architecture
section over here what you want to rap
about the karma sutra
yeah yeah you strike me as that kind of
guy
i mean i love sex but i do also like to
be prepared you know
it's good to know the positions
azerbaijan
and the architecture of it the civil war
the kama sutra guys over here yeah
you're waving a phone very brightly yes
sir
detroit i mean some would say it's too
obvious a suggestion but i i feel like i
have to take it
um i will take it any particular aspect
of detroit that you want us to really
focus on
everybody has their own opinions on this
and he's looking around to try and
crowdsource it
how much drink you've got oh grit
detroit and how much grit you have i
like that thank you very much
you can sit down now sir that was a very
good just like i'll stand up this is my
moment
now we're going to take one final one
this can come from anywhere
um it has to be really good though
what are you saying
this man is just shouting wanker at the
side of the stage
is it a suggestion is it heckle you've
been doing it since i walked on that's
why
i was like i can't i don't know if it is
a man shouting or it's just my dad's
voice in my head being like you're a
wanker son
you're a disappointment i mean it
it sounds awful coming out of any
american's mouth but i will i will
happily take it so
we have the civil war azerbaijan's
architecture detroit and how much grit
you have
the karma sutra and the british phrase
wanker which i will explain what it
means
but throughout the song this then lovely
people of the masonic temple in detroit
the forbes 30 under 30.
this is going to be a freestyle rap that
is a wrap made up on the spot based
entirely on those suggestions
if people walk in when i'm doing it tell
them it's made up on the spot because
otherwise it's going to look
really [ __ ] it's never been written it's
never going to be seen again and do not
worry it will not be anywhere near as
atrociously embarrassingly bad
as you're expecting a privately educated
middle class white british boy to be
thank you very much for those people who
seem very unconvinced this is going to
be fun if we can drop the beat my friend
let's show them how we do
yeah and crank that up on here for me a
little bit
i'm going to start with yours first
because it was such a nice suggestion
fist bump for the star yeah a fist bump
i touched my skin on the hand there
man on stage left saying chris you're a
wanker what does it mean
i'll define it for you if you are a guy
you go down to your balls you
like to have a hand shandy you might
thank for having the penis it's called
having a wank
a section of masturbation call me a
wanker
then my frustration is apparent it's
basically a horrible cuss
if you call me it will get fisticuffs i
might get rough
with you but i won't cause you've got
muscles and i clearly don't but that is
okay we can make best friends it sounds
real good in a british accent
but if you shouted at me i wouldn't
thank you
in american it sounds like this wanker
it doesn't sound nice i've heard it
before the last time i said it was
during the civil war
i saw all the bad guys open their mouths
i said you anchors go back to the south
they did admittedly i didn't fight in it
i wasn't alive i couldn't make that
finished
and people say chris you rap and sing
but have you ever seen
gone with the wind that's true i did
it's four hours long
i'm watching it going parts of this are
really wrong
they make me feel really dicey but look
at this she's wearing a nice dressy
scarlet o'hara that was in the novel
lived in a nice house never in a hobble
civil war it's really not that fun
unless you like
looking at massive guns abraham lincoln
back in the days he was like yeah we'll
free the south from slavery
admittedly i'm not sure that was his
main thing he was like well
i'm inviting everybody in i'm hearing
right to the future you and me
backstage do the karma sutra i'll get
the book out it's all the rage
i will do every position on every page
upside down
maybe inside out i thrust so hard that i
turn it out i'm really sorry
to put that in this rap it's horrible a
karma sutra prolapse
where does it come from english man i
believe
originally it's indian from the
subcontinent
and then i go near i travel up here
cause i've got
no fear far and wide like my blogging
ma'am
i'll go on a holiday azerbaijan chris
why would you go and see the country
well cause i like the
grand prix that's motor racing formula
one
a grand prix their circuit they've got
one but the best thing
if you really are able look at the
architecture it's so
stable built with triangles you can't
get off it
nice baroque domes none of that gothic
no brutalism
the streets are complete it's more kind
of baroque but no
concrete i don't like that last thing
i'm gonna spit i'm in detroit and we
know you guys got a lot of grip
you've got a lot of stones you've got a
lot of balls
so many of y'all in this berry hall have
got the grit too
it means you're gritty and tough it
means you always think yeah it's never
enough i'm gonna stick to the end
hang it till the finish there we go
detroit yeah like a little simple swish
boom there you go